the original version of pixar's luca was
going to be very different
from a huge monster movie ending to a
quest for magical tokens and a missing
john ratzenberger cameo
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing the alternate ending
of luca and some of the scenes and
storylines you never got to see
spoilers ahead of course so take care
before pixar's filmmakers landed on the
beautiful bittersweet ending for luka we
see in the final film
the movie's finale was originally going
to be more of a giant
monster battle this particular story
leaned much
more heavily than the final film into
the division between
humans and sea monsters setting them up
as two diametrically opposed factions or
worlds which director enrico cazaroza
compared in an interview with slash film
to the divide between the capulets and
montagues in romeo and juliet
although in the final movie the
townspeople of puerto rosso are still
fearful of sea monsters with a reward
being set up after a recent sighting of
one it sounds like in the earlier
version this confrontation between the
two worlds was going to be even more
intense
with the original plan being for alberto
to transform into a kraken an enormous
mythical sea monster that looks like a
humongous octopus or squid with luka
then standing up to defend and protect
his friend
however as casa rosa told cinema blend a
conversation he had with his own
real-life best friend
ended up inspiring him to completely
retool the film's finale
that movie changing chat was all about
their own friendship and how good
friends help each other grow
but eventually that often takes them
down very different paths in life
leading to bittersweet goodbyes for casa
rosa that's something he's experienced
several times in his own life
having left his home in italy for
america to pursue his dreams of
animation and filmmaking
and when he and his team put those ideas
together
storyboarded them and added composer dan
roma's score
they were hit by just how emotional it
was so the film dropped its colossal
kraken and as casaroza told
film focused instead on a kid's world
and stakes and goals
with this kind of slightly strange and
silly idea we're gonna ride into the
sunset with a vespa
curiously enough in the final film there
is actually an easter egg to a giant sea
monster movie though
by the poster for the disney adaptation
of jewel vern's twenty thousand leagues
under the sea which features an attack
by a giant squid
and there's also an illustration of a
giant crack and light creature wrapping
its tentacles around a boat on one of
the fisherman's maps
over the years krakens have popped up in
quite a few well-known movies including
the clash of the titans the pirates of
the caribbean
franchise and hotel transylvania 3
summer vacation
which is funny as the protagonist of
both that movie and luca are monsters
and both films are set during the summer
holidays
in fact the kraken plays a key part in
the ending of the third transylvania
movie
and given that film came out in 2018
while luca was still in development of
pixar i wonder if that might have also
influenced the decision to change luca's
finale when caso rosa first came up with
the idea for the movie
luca and alberto were not the only young
sea monsters who featured in the story
there was actually a group of them
giving the film what the director has
called a stand by me vibe referring to
the 1980s coming of age classic
in fact one of those additional sea
monster friends was called chicha
a name you'll probably recognize from
the final film as his original role was
completely rewritten to make him one of
bully boy er coles human sidekicks
instead
and there's a lot of lovely concept art
by chris zazaki which shows the original
trio of luca alberto ancicio getting up
to various high jinks in both their sea
monster and human forms
judging by cheecho's build in the final
film it looks like this character here
was a sea monster version of him it's
interesting that sea monster chicha had
crab claws for arms and carried around a
shell on his back like a hermit crab
and a remnant of this original idea made
its way into lucca's surname paguro
which means hermit crab in italian
as for julia it seems a human girl was
part of the group of male sea monster
friends even in early versions of the
story
however the filmmakers did experiment
with when exactly to reveal the truth to
her that her new pals were not
actually human you can see in the art of
luca book that at one point she learned
about them earlier as she goes swimming
with them in their sea monster form
and in another scene she's with all
three original sea creature friends and
they have their tails showing as they
sit down for dinner with massimo
in the end casa rosa and his team
decided that prolonging that reveal to
later in the film
added more tension and drama as producer
andrea warren told website io9
in what would have been another major
change to the story originally the kids
went on a much bigger quest that
involved magical tokens and their
intention was to become completely human
the final film certainly has shades of
the little mermaid with alberto
collecting items from the human world
and luca being forbidden from going to
the surface
but it sounds like this original plot
point would have made the film feel even
more like pixar's the little merman
likewise lucca's original storyline
where the young sea monsters set out to
become fully fledged human boys
also has a ring about it of the italian
children's novel pinocchio
which was adapted into a movie by disney
and there are actually several easter
eggs to the wooden marionette who
desperately wanted to become a real
human boy in the finnish pixar film
however casaroza says that storyline got
too complicated and he preferred a more
lyrical take on things so he decided to
strip
everything back to what he realized
should be the heart of the film
the friendship between luca and alberto
and he made those two children the
center of the story
further work of course was still needed
on the characters because as
luke is a bit introverted and very quiet
casaroza found that in some earlier
versions of the script it was difficult
for the audience to understand him
so subconsciously inspired by his love
of fellini's film eight and a half in
its dream sequences for the final film
kazuroza decided to take us literally
inside luca's head by showing us his
daydreams
another thing that evolved during
development was where the sea monsters
lived
originally they were hiding in plain
sight in their own town on an island as
you can see in this concept art here
from the art of luca book
and another piece of concept art shows
how the monster island was shaped like
an octopus
however casaroza and his team decided
that they only needed one town so they
just let the monsters be well hidden
instead
they did still keep the idea of an
island though but just as the location
of alberto's tower
and there may be a trace of the original
concept also in the way that one of the
fishermen is afraid to go there
do we really need to fish near the
island you worry too much
i don't know what if the old stories are
true some other interesting alternatives
that were considered for the monster
world are these illustrations of an
underwater town that's similar in luck
to the human town and which appears to
be situated almost directly underneath
portoroso
again there appears to be a remnant of
this original idea on the back of the
playing card that luca finds which is
the picture of a town in the top half
which is reflected in the lower half
there was also an alternative to
alberto's tower for his collection of
human objects in the form of a secret
hideout inside an upside down
semi-submerged shipwreck the entrance
was via the water with a dry
area in the hull above where alberto
stored his husits and whatsits
and it looks like the boat was located
in a cave again giving it a bit of a
little mermaid vibe
a regular pixar feature that didn't make
it into the final movie is a cameo by
john ratzenberger
before seoul the cheers actor had voiced
at least one character in every pixar
film
in seoul ratzenberger didn't voice any
character however the movie's
co-director kemp powers said that a
tribute was made to him
by a non-speaking character who appears
briefly in the subway
as for lucca casaroza confirmed that
ratzenberger is not in the film and said
on twitter that he hoped to start a new
tradition of having the good dinosaur
director peter sohn voice a character in
each new pixar movie
in lucas zone is the voice of chicha
well my head
i'm curious as to whether ratson now
retired from pixar films for good or of
his absence from seoul and lucas related
to the pandemic as both films were
completed during that time
intriguingly i found an interesting old
man sea monster character in some
concept art that i wonder if he might
have played
and if you want to discover all the
pixar easter eggs which did make it into
luca
tap here to watch my full things you
missed video and my next video will be
all the incredible deleted scenes from
raya and the last dragon which i'll link
here and
in the video description too and if you
want to check out more of the gorgeous
concept art from lucca there's also
links in the description where you can
get the art of luca book
so do you wish any of these deleted
scenes or story ideas have been in the
final movie
let me know what you think in the
comments and if you enjoyed this then do
like and subscribe it's hugely
appreciated
next you can tap left to learn all the
hidden messages and meanings and the
ending of luca
including what alberto's secret
catchphrase really means
for tat wright for another disney
deleted scenes video thanks for watching
and see you next time yupikai movie
lovers